Many social animals, like humans,
have large brains and sophisticated cognition.
Is this true for social carnivores like lions and hyenas
or are solitary meat-eaters like leopards and tigers
just as smart?
To get the treat from this puzzle box,
the Hyenas didn’t take long to figure out
they needed to pull the rope.
Lions came in second. Some spent time exploring
the box, which is also indicative of having smarts.
This leopard is also a busy explorer, and scores.
But only 6 of the 11 leopards tested opened the box.
Tigers came in last. Only two of these seven
big cats, like this one, opened the door.
The task doesn’t require being socially intelligent.
Yet, the group-living carnivores were better at it.
That suggests that there’s something about
being social that makes us smarter overall.